我们来看一下这个片子。
杀人回忆。
先说一下他这个故事的脉络。
两个主角。
一个。
小镇警察。
中康我们就。
称之为警察警警A。
一个小镇警察警A。
一个。
首尔的。
刑仅上过大学的。
在那880年代啊，80年代上过大学的那种警察。
属于那种刑警。
啊上过警官大学呀，专门学刑侦的，从首尔来。
一个小镇上发生了一个连环奸杀案。
先上岸。
连完呢。
然后这件事情。
造成了全国的轰动。
他是。
本地的负责的刑警，他是听了听说这个奸杀案来支援的。
然后两个人因为这个事情开始侦破这个案件。
呃，第一个嫌疑人。
第二个嫌疑人。
第三个嫌疑人。
第四个嫌疑人差不多是到第四个嫌疑人的时候。
第一个嫌疑人，本地的一个。
有点残疾的一个傻孩子。
他抓到的。
然后呢，他确定就是他。
因为这个这个家伙呢有点弱智。
天天就喜欢。
再加上这个年纪，20岁左右的年纪弱智，天天就喜欢跟着这个镇上的大姑娘小媳妇，跟着人家屁股后面，真好啊真好啊。
那那人心惶惶嘛，所以矛头肯定先指向了他。
再加上他又从他的口供中得到了一些证据。
所以警A想要治他的罪。
但是警闭不同意。
警密说证据不足。
而且他有残疾。
把那个女的五花大绑奸杀。
他做不到。
然后最后证明确实不是他，然后看又找第二个。
第二个嫌疑人呃，第三个嫌疑人就这么一个一个往下涨，两个人呢意见一直不太统一。直到第四个嫌疑人，确实不管是从警A还是从警B，这两个主角，还是从咱们观众的角度，基本上都确定就是他就是他。
就是他。
就是他干的。
很生气，就他。
但是。
在最后时刻DNA检测。
在现场采样的精子。
样本。
跟他不同意，无奈只能把他放走了。
到最后。
影片。
也不知道，也没有说。
犯人是谁？
坏人是谁？
因为这个片子在呃来自真实案件，在韩国也是悬案。
当然。
去年年底的时候，有新闻报道说。
通过DNA排查。
找到了。
当年的这个凶手。
但是这个影片里面是没有的。
没有找到凶手。
结尾甚至是。
十几年以后。
17年以后。
这个颈A。
已经不做警察了。
在卖卖小商品，做小买卖。
开着车送货的过程中。
经过这个小镇。
下了车回到了当年的那个案发现场。
忍不住回到了当年的案发现场。
又看了看当时发现第一具尸体的那个。
下水道。
那蹲着看。
然后有一个小孩走过来说，你在这蹲着看什么？
说你真奇怪。
他说之前也有一个人来这里看过。
然后他就非常警觉说谁。
他是说。
一个很普通的男人，他说那他说什么？
他说他之前在这里做过一些事儿，他想来看一看，回忆回忆。
你毛骨悚然的一个结局。
这时候这个警察。
突然转脸看向镜头，这个也是电影电影里面非常。
呃，牛逼的一个镜头之一。
就宋康奥这个演员突然转向镜头。
盯着镜头看了好久。
导演就想表达这个坏人，我们虽然没有抓住你。
但是我看着你呢。
非常的棒。
就是这样一个理。
我们说他是负能量吗？
他是负能量吗？
结果是结局可能是结果啊，坏人没抓到嘛？我们很压抑呀，这个电影确实很压抑。
看着很难受，你知道吗？
我看过呃。
七八遍吧。
每一次都。
蒸气难受。
因为这个电影太好了，他能把他带进去。
但是我们说。
我们是编剧，我们先从这个情绪里面跳出来。
我们先进入一个无我的状态，你不要在乎你的那点小悲伤，小难过。我们是搞剧本的，我们从剧本角度好吧，因为。
我说过，我们编剧要跟剧剧中的每一个人物产生共情呀，你不能光跟他们井A井B产生共情呀。
对吧。
你得跟任何一个人产生共情呀。如果编剧拘泥于说一个结果的。
正正或者负坏人有没有抓到，那你这个剧本没法写了。
你这个剧本没法写的。
你在乎的是警A井B，他俩没有抓到坏人。哎呀，这这么好的两个警察没有抓到坏人。哎呀，我就是这不是编剧该干的事情，这是观众该干的事情，这是你设局勾引观众做的事情。观众。
进共情我们这两个男主角替他们着急，替他们难过。
这是观众的事情，编剧要共情每一个人。
编剧要共情。
1234都得共情，他都是你的人物。
你怎么能在乎？
一两个人的所谓的结局的正义呢。那我跟你说，来，我经常看到有一种片子，一个孤胆英雄。
潜入了敌方老潮。
对吧然后呢，为了不惊动。
他以底板嘛，他就自己孤胆英雄嘛，潜入金华老巢，需要干掉那个boss，那个boss是坏人呀，大boss是坏人呀。
比如说这个大boss在一个建筑物里，或者在一个游轮上他潜水线从啊啊游过去，对吧？爬上这个游轮。
不敢放枪，要悄悄的潜入进去，然后一路上杀掉了几十个。
小喽啰。
然后最后杀掉这个坏人。
大boss伸张的正义，对不对？你觉得啊这种结局是正能量啊正义。
正义什么呀？
那些小喽啰啊。
人家不就是来上班的吗？
对不对？那小萝卜就不是人吗？他们没有家庭，没有爱恨情仇吗？
他们只不过是应聘到一个公司上个班，然后这个公司的老板恰好是个坏人，就被你给杀了。
你还是觉得自己挺挺豪横的。
是不是这么个道理啊？
不要去给我谈结果的正义。
结果的正义让观众去想。
勾引观众去去琢磨结果争议不争义。我们是编剧。
对吧我们是没有感情的编剧，冷血的编剧，我们跟任何任何一块都要产生共情，懂吗？我之前第一课就跟你们说过，跟空调给我产生共情。
为什么你到开玩笑吗？
井A井B，我们当然要跟他们产生共情，他们是主角，但是1234你就不产生共情了吗？
被奸杀的那些女孩，你就不产生共情了吗？
甚至这个最后那个凶手你就不产生共情了吗？
还有是这个小镇。
这小镇的普通人。
他们遭受了什么？
不要去跟我讲。
结局正义不正义。
关起门来说啊。
不重要。
好吗？
我说的正能量一定要正，是指主题的正义。
我们反过来看杀人回忆。
这么好的片子，这么牛逼的片子，它的主题当然是正能量。
当然是正义。
我跟你讲，这是一个什么片子？
这其实从类型上来说，它根本不是一个t。
根本不是一个碳安平。
这个片子从大类上属于爱情片。
爱情。
听不懂对吧？
因为爱情片有个小小的分类，叫兄弟情。
兄弟情。
他其实是讲景A跟景B通过一件事情互相影响，互相成长，互相成全。
你仔细去把这个片子的结构扒开来看，从结构上它其实是按照这条线走的。
井A是什么？
小镇警察粗俗不堪。
然后呢，白天当警察晚上逛窑子呃，也不是逛窑子呢，唱KTV。
然后。
这个他的辖区发生奸察案了，这个一这个嫌疑犯一就是他找来的吗？
那个残疾的那个男孩面目可憎。然后呢，成天看到大姑娘小媳妇儿就喜欢跟着他就觉得那就他了。
对吧没有证据没有证据来把人家小小孩的鞋拿来，在犯罪现场摁了个脚印儿，然后拿照片一拍。你看犯罪现场有他脚印，哎呀对吧？然后哎没有口供啊踹上去打把那个呃呃那个嫌疑人一打到刑讯弥鼓。
他就是这样一个警察。
所以他什么它代表一种。
一种警察或者叫一种人。
对吧警币跟它截然相反。
截然相反。
来自首尔。
刑警大学高材生。
长得还帅，我们知道宋康浩不是是是比较长得比较比较差点意思的。然后呢，这个这个这个是个帅哥。
高大挺拔，浓眉大眼。
就是1个1.85米版的朱士帽尔。
很像的很像朱世茂。然后呢呃这个办案要讲证据，讲流程，然后把这个案子上来就定性成呃连环奸杀案。然后用FBI的那一套理论要搞那个叫什么犯罪侧写，对吧？要分析这个就他是这个教科书班的。
然后呢，在一上他他对了，他认为那不是他对吧？他认为就是他，然后两个人第一次发生了争吵，最后发现一确实不是一，他很没有面子，他占据了上风。
然后到二的时候，然后。
那就他主导了，现在他得势了吗？
他这个科学方法得失了吗？但是。
呃，搞错了。
景A呢又通过自己的实战小技巧，他比较野路子。
通过自己的实战小技巧又争回一分，他又得失了，对吧？两个人是你来我往，而且当中还打架撕破脸。
到最后到四站的时候，京诚合作。
他也露到什么程度呢？
他当中到23这里的时候。
好去算命。
他找了个大仙儿，说你给我算一算，我这个我我现在要抓一个嫌犯，你给我算一算，上哪儿逮他。然后这个大仙儿给了他一壶什么液体，然后告诉咱还要到犯罪现场抓一把泥，撒到这个液体里，把这液体往水上一泼，等干了以后就会出来嫌犯的脸。
他都信了。
他都信了，然后呢，这个笔呢就坚持要用什么DNA测序，坚持这个这个呃各种那个科技破案。
在这个案件当中，受害人一共有六七个。
他们又一次发现一个受害人的时候，这个受害人开始犯罪现场，清理的没有那么干净。
然后呢，他们发现一个问题，就是这个呃他们终于得到。
这个犯罪嫌疑人的经验了，其实也就得到DNA了。但是一般这种强奸现场。
呃，如果现场保存了的话。
其实是可以得到阴毛的。
就有证据是可以得到阴毛的。阴毛因为很容易脱落，在实施强奸的过程中，它是一个重要证据。但是呢他们发现这个现场只有精液，没有阴毛。
然后警察A呢就。
就初步判定这是个白虎。
这是个白虎，他采取什么措施呢？就去所有的澡堂天天洗澡。
天天在那蹲，而且要看对吧？
就是说这两个警察截然相反的性格。
走各自的极端，都有自己重大的缺陷。我跟你讲，警闭也不是没有缺陷，他很固执，很高傲，有话不说出来，不愿意分享。而且呢他为什么从首尔让人撵出来，对吧？你作为一个首都的大刑警跑到一个小镇来破案，对吧？你是怎么回事？你。
两个人都有自己认魂。
这就是典型的。
那种爱情片或者叫兄弟片那种类型片就是。
两个人互相成全，互相成长，互相。
圆满。
而且这结局更明显，结局两个人面对第四个95%就确定是凶手的这个最后的这个最讨厌的这个嫌疑犯的时候。
两个人不光经诚合作，就两个人终于站到一块对付这个4。
两个人换了一个位置。
一向很稳的。
讲究证据的。
讲究科学的呃大学生刑警紧闭。
说没有证据，我他妈崩了他拿着一把枪要去杀了这个嫌疑犯4。
一向鲁莽的伪造证据的，不三不四的流里流气的小镇警察A拦住了他，告诉他不行，我们是警察。
这样杀了他还不行。
两个人身份互换了。
两个人不光互相成就，互相圆满，互相改变，都他妈互相交叉了。
懂吗？
所以从这个线索你去看，你告诉我这个片子是个什么片子。
不是个探案片。
当然，杀人回忆是里面最重要的事情，这个坏人太坏了是最重要的事情。但是从类型上说，他不是探片，他讲的是两个男人的成长。
两个男人的成长。
而且再说句题外话，这个片子我们看他的年代，他是86年的事情，就这个片子是零几年拍的。但是这个呃片中的案件是86年的事情。
86年有个什么事情？
韩国有非常汹涌的。
呃，学学生的运动。
那个还有一个韩国片出租车司机也是也是讲那个嘛，就非常汹涌的学生运动。
等于是当时的大学生，当时的知识分子跟工农阶级在社会上是有矛盾的。
那么他们俩恰恰就是。
代表了。
各自的族群。
所以这是个片子。
从类型上来说，他不是个。
他是两个男人的成长。
这个兄弟情的片子。
所以他的主题是什么？
两个男人。
在经历共同一个事件以后。
都变发生了成长和蜕变。
都变成了更好的人。
不正能量吗？
主题。
剧本的正义实现了。
这个片子他就是正常量。
这个问题我们本来是没想这么早说的，因为比较费解，我不想影响大家的思路。
就先按照传统的。
正能量。
去写自己的故事，对吧？
我说过正能量啊，你就用那些最原始的最根红苗正的那些正能量的词。
最颠不颠簸不破的那些词儿。
从古至今都是正能量的那些词儿，去确定自己什么叫正能。
因为在现实生活中。
什么是正能量？
没有那么好区分的。
所以我才反复强调。
我们的主题首先要要正能量，而且要是那种。
最普世的怎么。
就是这个道理。
如果有不懂的，我们还可以在。
还可以再聊。
但是今天我们就先说到这儿。
嗯，作业大家别忘了做好吧，1500字左右的。
一个完整的含有八要素的故事。
再找磨个部分。
自己选一个突破一下。
就把它。
我说过像有一个好知识点，你这故事就7788了。
其他的补齐。
按照顺序。
写一个线性的故事。
至于以后怎么玩花，我们以后再说。
想写剧本的也不用着急。
写完这个作业，我们就开始搞剧本。
下课。